how are you doing sir
hey brother how you doing can't complain
um so i'm curious uh when listen first i
want to start with i'm a fan of your
work and it's great to talk to you today
um i'm curious when you're brought in on
a project uh like for example tom and
jerry
how much does the director sort of know
because you're obviously very funny and
can improvise in the moment
how much are they sort of asking you to
stick to the script and how much are
they sort of like bring you
and you know what can you do with this
that's a great question because tim
story uh the director is a good friend
of mine we did right along two together
and so you know there there is already a
shorthand that tim
and i have so you know and i i think
that was part of it you know i really
think that
we we just know each other so well and
know each other's work pro
our work styles are very compatible so
it is it really depends i think
on how well let's say the actor knows
the director well you know
in this case like we just know each
other so well we'd only have to say like
oh that we don't it's not cut and dry
out this is the part where you just
stick to
script there's a part where you
improvise just because we've worked
so long you know i think tim trusts me
enough where you have
i have an acute sense of story and i
the older i get the more i just try to
track the whole script
it's it's funny the older i get i the
less and less i even think about
myself if that makes sense i'm just
tracking it for the story
knowing where i come in and knowing what
what my job is i'm a mechanic and i'm
i'm let's say servicing one side of that
car and
and and i'm working with people i love
and trust and people like michael and
chloe and
rob and colin who i'm huge fans of and
then growing up on tom and jerry and
as a kid and genuinely loving it it was
it was very easy it was a very easy job
one of my one of the coolest easiest
jobs i've had
in the film you get to destroy like a
huge pig
and i'm curious it made me think um in
your career
how many times have you had to do
something where you the director pulls
you aside and says listen
we only have one take you have to make
it or do you know what i mean like the
pressure
of delivering something one take oh yeah
um a lot i mean i mean from hangover
movies to transformers and
you know and i've acted with cgi before
and transformers and
um and especially in independent movies
like
actually in in television television
like community
so much stuff where in independence so
you could have big budget
things where you actually will have more
at bats
you know um pardon the pun but it's it's
but at times when um i think especially
in television
and and in an independent movie making
you only have one chance
you know you only have one take and i
think though those are
um those are more stressful but but they
all they all have as challenges you know
so um so to answer your question um many
times and more than you think
watching tom and jerry made me think
about roger rabbit
and what they accomplished in the 80s
because what zemeckis did in the 80s
doesn't make sense
to what what he managed to do and i'm
just curious if you had newfound
respect for roger rabbit after making
tom and jerry
absolutely i mean and watching the film
in his totality
it's so hard i think it's so hard to
create that universe to make
to give continuity to that universe and
then having you know
having um you know the cast
and vfx and tim's story you know just
tell the story you know in in in in a
flow
is it's incredibly hard and uh
much respect and it it takes longer you
know it really does so
it was uh it's truly an honor to see
yeah and to have like the best rope
almost like the best seat in the house
you get to see how they're how they're
making it's pretty cool
completely um great to talk with you
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating
thank you so much thanks brother
appreciate it always good talking to you